Höchste Zeit für einen Blick hinter die Kulissen des Rasenfunks, eine eurer Lieblingssendungen in jedem Jahr. Frank und ich freuen uns darüber immer sehr, deswegen sind wir auch wieder beide hier, um eure Fragen zu beantworten, aber auch einige Ankündigungen zu machen. Denn wie immer eigentlich beim Rasenfunk tut sich ein bisschen was. Seid gespannt.
Rasenfunk? What the hell is Rasenfunk? Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Er wird einfach nicht alt, dieser O-Ton. Oder dieser Jingle, diese O-Ton-Kombination. Frank, schön, dass du da bist.
Das stimmt, Max. Schön, dass ich da sein darf.
Warum gibt's diese Sendung jetzt erst im April und nicht wie sonst zum Jahreswechsel?
Keine Ahnung.
Na doch. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Vielleicht waren wir ein bisschen arg okkupiert und es wird vielleicht auch so ein roter Faden dieser Sendung werden, dass es insgesamt sehr sehr viel ist mit dem Rasenfunk aktuell und auch mit vielen Themen neben dem Rasenfunk.
Vor allem Transkription. KI generell ist gar nicht so interessant, aber Transkription ist eigentlich im Moment so ein bisschen unser Kryptonit. Wobei ich dazu sagen muss, wir investieren da jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Zeit. Es ist mehr, wir sind mehr in dem Stadium, es zu beobachten und Veränderungen immer mal wieder auszuprobieren und zu sehen, hilft es für uns. Aber wenn ihr da Erfahrung habt, vor allem was das Thema Speaker Diorization, also die Unterscheidung von Sprechern angeht, das wäre interessant für bereits gerenderte Folgen quasi.
Genau.
Aber wir haben im Moment auch das ganze Archiv noch als Mehrspur-Dateien. Das heißt, wir könnten auch die Spuren getrennt analysieren. Das ist nicht das größte Problem, aber vor allem, wenn es darum geht, kompliziertes Vokabular zu erkennen und da eine hohe Treffsicherheit hinzubekommen, dann nehme ich gerne jeden Tipp und jede Hilfe an.
Genau, wir hatten das ja schon zwei, drei Mal in der 10-jährigen Geschichte des Rasenfunks, dass Menschen sich mit irgendeinem technischen Thema beschäftigt haben und dann auf uns zugekommen sind und gesagt haben, hier können wir euch eine App programmieren oder können wir XY machen. Ganz herzliche Grüße an die Angesprochenen, hier mit indirekt Angesprochenen. Vielleicht ist es ja diesmal auch der Fall, dass ihr sowieso in dem Bereich Transkription unterwegs seid und da vielleicht auch einen großen Korpus bräuchtet an gar nicht so einfach verarbeiteten Daten. Den haben wir. Also damit können wir bieten. Wir stellen uns auch als Forschungsobjekt zur Verfügung. Sehr gerne. Waren wir ja linguistisch auch schon durchaus manchmal. Ganz herzliche Grüße an Simon an dieser Stelle. War es das mit dem Technik-Update?
Ich glaube ja.
Genug der Einsen und Nullen. Kommen wir zu euren Hörerinnen-Fragen, also jetzt der zweite große Block dieser Sendung. Und diesmal haben wir es eben so gemacht, wie vorher schon angekündigt, dass ich mir auch eure Fragen vorher angeguckt habe. Wir machen das jetzt nicht so, dass wir so grob über jede Frage drüber gehen, sondern wir haben auch versucht, sie inhaltlich zu gruppieren. Das heißt, es kann jetzt auch sein, dass eure Frage im Wortlaut nicht vorkommt. Ich denke aber, dass wir bis auf die privaten und hinter die Kulissen Fragen hoffentlich alles abgedeckt haben werden mit dieser Sendung. Und die erste Frage, die immer kommt, geht rund um die Downloads, um die Reichweite des Rasenfunks. Da hat zum Beispiel Hakuna Matata gefragt, hängen die Hörerinnenzahlen davon ab, wann der Podcast veröffentlicht wird? Gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen einer Sonntag- und einer Montagaufnahme? Und soll ich dir was sagen, Frank, als ich die Frage zum ersten Mal gelesen habe, was da meine Reaktion war? Das war eigentlich eine interessante Frage. Habe ich schon ganz lange nicht mehr nachgeguckt, ob es da einen Unterschied gibt. Und deshalb bin ich für Hakuna Matata und für alle anderen, die sich für unsere Downloads interessieren, bin ich wieder bei Podergy tief reingestiegen und bei YouTube und habe mir die Downloads rausgelassen. Es folgen jetzt viele Zahlen. Wenn das zu viel ist, dann schreibt es im Forum, dann kann ich die da auch nochmal posten. Das ist gar kein Problem. Ihr wisst ja, wir machen da kein Geheimnis drum um unsere Zahlen. Warum auch? Deswegen gehen wir jetzt mal die Feeds durch. Und der reichweitenstärkste Feed ist der der Bundesliga-Männer-Feed. Da habe ich jetzt jeweils die Zahlen zusammengesucht seit dem 1. Juli. Das heißt, wir haben so grob ein halbes Jahr mit drin, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr. Das ergibt einfach insofern Sinn, im August geht die Sendung los, im Juni rödelt der Rasenfunk Royale noch vor sich hin. Das heißt, ein guter Cut ist da zu machen. Wir hatten 1,1 Millionen Downloads seit dem 1. Juli und 730.000 Views bei YouTube.
Ganz kurzer Einwand, Max. Seit dem 1. Juli ein halbes Jahr. Ich glaube, das muss man erklären. Bis wann gehen die Daten?
Ach so, bis zum 1. April müsste das sein. Oder Ende März, genau. Also es ist ein bisschen mehr sogar.
Aber das ist ein bisschen mehr als ein halbes Jahr, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Ich denke immer in Saisons, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist für mich so eine Hinrunde.
Das wollte ich nur aufklären, weil das klang für mich gerade ein bisschen.
Ja, okay. Du hast gesagt.
Nach mehr als einem halben Jahr, also es ist wahrscheinlich die Dreiviertel-Saison, weil da fehlt ja nur noch April und Mai und im Mai hört ja die Saison schon auf.
Ja, aber Mai kommt auch der Royale im Juni. Das heißt quasi, der haut halt richtig rein.
Und der ist da im Endeffekt nicht drin, weil 1. Juli natürlich nach der Saison ist.
Genau, und der Hintergrund war, dass ich möglichst aktuelle Zahlen haben wollte, auch nach der Aufteilung, Trennung, Schwerpunkt und Spieltagssendung. Also eben, wir haben so rund 1,8 Millionen Views bzw. Downloads. Dazu muss man aber sagen, das heißt erst mal gar nichts, wie viele davon auch wirklich wie lange reingehört oder reingesehen haben. Ist ganz schwer zu sagen. Das heißt, lasst euch jetzt auch nicht von... Wir wollen auch jetzt hier mit keiner Zahl flexen, weil kann man gar nicht sagen, wie viel so eine Sendung hat. Aber interessant ist natürlich die Entwicklung. Wir haben rund um die erfolgreichsten Sendungen sind immer Vorschau- oder Rückblicksendungen. Also die Vorschau, die hatte wieder rund die 40.000 Insgesamtdownloads und Views waren sogar noch ein bisschen mehr. Die Spieltagssendungen, die haben immer um die 25.000 Downloads und die Fokus-Sendungen haben um die 18.000 Downloads. Und ja, ich greife die Frage auf natürlich, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ja, es variiert sehr deutlich zwischen den einzelnen Vereinen. Und ja, es ist ungefähr so, wie ihr es euch vorstellt. Bei YouTube ist es sehr, sehr schwierig, irgendetwas Generalisierendes zu sagen. Also da kann man quasi diese Aufteilung zwischen Spieltag und Schwerpunkt nicht so gut machen.
Lass mich noch mal ganz kurz rein, wenn du sagst, es variiert sehr stark, kannst du grob so die die Ausschläge nennen? Also so ein Bayern-Fokus hat der dann 35.000 Downloads?
Ne, ne, ne. Also interessanterweise kommen wir mit den Fokus-Sendungen eigentlich nie über die Spieltagssendungen raus. Was überraschend ist, weil die Halbwertszeit einer Fokus-Sendung ja viel länger ist und ich bekomme auch die Rückmeldung, dass Menschen manchmal ein paar Wochen später noch mal Schwerpunkt XY hören. Auf der anderen Seite muss man allerdings da auch sagen, dass die Download-Zahlen für die Spieltagssendungen sehr wahrscheinlich auch insofern geschönt sind, weil da wissen wir, dass es auch Leute gibt, die nur einzelne Kapitel zu einzelnen Spielen hören. Also das sind da nicht 25.000 Menschen, die diese Sendung von A bis Z durchgehört haben. Bei den Fokussendungen wird aber wahrscheinlich der Prozentsatz derjenigen, die das komplett gehört haben, viel höher sein. Das heißt, wenn man danach geht, kann es sein, dass die vielleicht sogar auf Augenhöhe sind.
Wie du schon gesagt hast, ist es immer schwierig mit solchen Download- und View-Zahlen zu operieren, weil die gerade bei so längeren Sendungen wie beim Rasenfunk generell ganz schwer eine Aussagekraft geben. Wer schon mal YouTube-Videos veröffentlicht hat, der kennt diese Retention, diese Fewer-Retention-Kurven. Wie lange bleiben die Zuschauer dran? Und da sieht man eben innerhalb der Videos immer ganz schöne Kurven und Veränderungen. Das ist beim Podcast am Ende genauso. Und daher lässt sich schwer. Darum gucken wir auch und darum ist es ja. Habt ihr am Anfang schon gehört, Max musste auch erst mal reingucken und fand die Frage interessant, weil so richtig abhängig machen wollen wir uns von den Statistiken ja auch nicht.
Genau für uns zählt die eine Zahl. Das ist was im Monat reingekommen ist an Überweisungen und an Support-Beiträgen. Und danach müssen wir uns richten. Bei YouTube ist es komplett erratisch. Wir haben einige alte Videos, die über 50.000 Views haben. Es gibt einige Spieltags-Sendungen, die haben über 30.000 Views. Also sprich, der Theorie nach mehr als sie Downloads hätten als klassischer Audio-Podcast. Der Schnitt ist allerdings viel niedriger. Der ist um die 13.000 für die Spieltags-Sendungen und auch für die Schwerpunkte durchaus. Und wir hören jetzt, wenn wir beim Audio-Podcast bleiben, 30 Prozent so grob wie Apple, Podcasts und Spotify. Und der Rest verteilt sich auf andere Plattformen. Spotify ist hier zurückgegangen in den letzten Jahren. Und interessanterweise ist auf Platz zwei der Länder, in denen wir gehört werden, ist die USA. Liegen die USA noch vor Schweiz und Österreich? Keine Ahnung, was da mit unseren direkten Nachbarn los ist. Aber es ist so, zumindest laut Podgy. Und um auf die Frage zu antworten, der Tag spielt keinerlei Rolle. Interessanterweise ist es aber so, dass in unseren Top Ten in dieser Saison die Spieltage eins bis sechs sind. Das heißt, es scheint so zu sein, dass die Saison-Vorschau-Menschen die den Rasenfunk nicht kannten, die dann vielleicht hängenbleiben, aber offenbar auch wieder abspringen. Denn irgendwann kommen wir dann wieder auf dem Normal-Dimo raus. Die Schwerpunkte hinken deutlich hinter den Spieltags-Sendungen hinterher. Also der erfolgreichste ist Bayern auf Rang 11, unsere Top-Sendungen St. Pauli dann auf 16, Hoffenheim auf 23, VfB Stuttgart auf 28 und Borussia Dortmund auf 30. Also speaking of, es ist nicht vorhersehbar. Es ist auch im Podcastbereich nicht vorhersehbar. Was aber insgesamt zu sagen ist, zu dem Feed Bundesliga Männer. Der Podcast stagniert von den Download-Zahlen her. Wir haben im Grunde ungefähr das, was wir in den Vorjahren auch schon hatten. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die haben wir seit mindestens drei Jahren, dass sich da eigentlich nicht mehr so wirklich viel tut. YouTube wächst, aber total erratisch. Es ist nicht nachvollziehbar und wir wissen ja auch, wie wichtig beim YouTube Thumbnail und Titel sind. Da sind wir schon ein bisschen pointierter geworden. Vielleicht müssten wir manchmal sogar noch mal das Thumbnail wechseln. Aber da haben wir auch gar keine Lust drauf, weil wir wollen eigentlich gar nicht so die Leute einfischen. Wir wollen schon, dass wir gefunden werden auf YouTube. Aber wir wissen ja, dass jemand, der auf ein total reißerisches Thumbnail klickt, dass der, wenn der dann sieht, das dauert jetzt zweieinhalb Stunden die Sendung, dass der dann sowieso wieder weg ist. Und wir sind nicht monetarisiert auf YouTube, was uns im Algorithmus definitiv auch schadet.
Und bei YouTube könnt ihr übrigens selber reingucken. Ihr seht ja die Few-Zahlen, ihr seht zwar keine Entwicklung, aber ich gucke hier gerade nebenbei auch aus Interesse auf die Bundesliga-Männer-Playlist bei YouTube. Und da sieht man ganz gut die Schwankungen. Da ist eben die Analyse vom 12. Spieltag bei 20.000 und die vom 14. bei 9.000. Da muss natürlich klar sein, Max hat es ja eben schon erwähnt, YouTube ist halt eine Algorithmus-Plattform. Selbst wenn ihr uns dort abonniert habt, wissen wir nicht, wie gut ihr mitbekommt, wenn wir ein neues Video veröffentlichen. Das heißt, ihr müsstet da schon in eure Abo-Ansicht gucken und alles entsprechend einstellen, damit ihr zuverlässig jedes Abo, jedes Video zu Gesicht bekommt, das ein abonnierter Kanal veröffentlicht. Wohingegen das selbst bei mir zum Beispiel, mein YouTube-Verhalten ist fast komplett Startzeiten abhängig. Und meine Startzeite ändert sich relativ schnell, wenn sich meine aktuelle Tendenz zu irgendwelchen Themen ändert. Ist ja okay und aus YouTube-Sicht völlig verständlich, ist aber für uns als Publisher natürlich ein sehr wenig berechenbarer Faktor.
Total. Ihr hattet das ja bestimmt auch schon, wenn ihr YouTube öfter verwendet, dass euch irgendwann auch fällt, hey, wo sind eigentlich die Videos von Kanal XY? Hat der oder sie gar nichts veröffentlicht? Und dann schaut ihr auf den Kanal und sagt, nee, der hat ganz normal im Rhythmus weiter veröffentlicht. Ich habe es einfach nicht mehr gesehen, weil ich den Fehler gemacht habe, ein Video zu was ist die Konklave, wie funktioniert sie anzugucken und mir jetzt nur noch das vorgeschlagen wird. Ich hatte das auch noch mit anderen Themen im letzten Jahr. Also was aber damit zu sagen ist, es macht keinen Unterschied, wann wir veröffentlichen. Die Downloads sind gut, sind auch so, dass viele, also independent Podcasts würden sich sehr freuen über solche Zahlen und die Corporate-Podcasts, die lachen da drüber. Aber es wächst nur noch auf YouTube. Das war ja auch der Befund, den wir schon die letzten Jahre hatten. Und da ist es aber auch total schwer zu timen. Und wir machen ja auch ganz viele Dinge gar nicht richtig für YouTube. Also am Anfang habe ich manchmal noch Sendungen später auf YouTube veröffentlicht, weil es eben da, du musst quasi den Sendungen Luft zum Atmen geben, in Anführungszeichen, dass sie eben ihre Views einsammeln können. Denn wenn ich zwei Sendungen kurz nacheinander veröffentliche, dann zeigt YouTube logischerweise, wenn, dann überhaupt nur eine davon auf der Startseite an. Aber irgendwann fand ich das dann albern, dass es den Audio-Podcast schon gibt und ich ans Video noch denken muss. Und dass ich damit ja auch die YouTube-Fans, die wirklich alles gucken, die gibt es ja auch, dass ich die dann damit benachteile und deswegen wird jetzt einfach wild rausgehauen. Und also das ist jetzt auch nicht so, das ist jetzt keine YouTube-Strategie, die wir da haben. Kommen wir in Abgrenzung zum Bundesliga-Männer-Feed, zum Bundesliga-Frauen-Feed. Ich versuche jetzt ein bisschen schneller durchzugehen. Da haben wir, also ihr erinnert euch Bundesliga-Männer, 1,1 Millionen Downloads und 700.000 Views. Beim Bundesliga-Frauen haben wir 50.000 Downloads und 35.000 Views. Also ein deutlicher Abfall. Aber hier sehen wir, dass sich was tut. Der YouTube-Schnitt ist so bei anderthalbtausend ungefähr, der Podcast-Schnitt so bei zweieinhalbtausend, 2,2. Ist auch hier schwierig zu sagen. Wir sehen allerdings, dass die Folgen gehört werden. Wir haben logischerweise bei diesem Feed auch keine Altkartei-Leichen mit drin. Das darf man auch nicht komplett vergessen. Leute, die uns für Ewigkeiten abonniert haben im Männerfeed und das noch auf der Autodownload haben, aber schon ewig nicht mehr reingehört haben, das haben wir in diesem neuen Feed logischerweise nicht. Das heißt, ja, die Zahlen sind deutlich niedriger. Ich nehme aber wahr, auch an der kleinen Community, die sich quasi in diesem Feed so ein bisschen zu bilden scheint, dass es da eine Entwicklung gibt und dass man sich da jetzt auch nicht blenden sollte, nur von den geringeren Zahlen und wir machen es ja nicht für die Zahlen. Deswegen, also ich muss sagen, mit der Entwicklung von dem Feed bin ich persönlich zufriedener als mit dem von Männerfeed. Frank nickt für alle, die jetzt nur hören. Schauen wir auf die Ligatur, unser, tja, Sorgen- und Lieblingskind. Man kann es nicht anders sagen. Ligatur hatte 300.000 Podcast-Downloads und 100.000 bei YouTube. Die große Frage ist, wie unterscheiden sich die Zweitligasendungen von den Europasendungen? Bei YouTube haben wir bei der zweiten Liga ein paar Ausreißer nach oben. Also wir hatten mal 12.000 bei einem HSV und lauter ein Video und 9.000 bei Fortuna Düsseldorf und Nürnberg. Man glaubt da schon herauszulesen bei YouTube, dass die etwas bekannteren und reichweitenstärkeren Vereine auch eine höhere Reichweite bekommen. Wobei man zum HSV, wie du dazu sagen musst, wenn Niesbohmhof da ist, haben wir natürlich auch die entsprechende Crowd.
Kleiner Livefun-Fact, das weil ich es zufällig beim Durchklicken gerade gesehen habe, das HSV Kaiserslautern Video ist das beste Video der letzten 90 Tage insgesamt.
Ah ja, guck mal.
Mit 12.500 Views innerhalb dieser 90 Tage.
Danke Nies für deinen Besuch. Das hat sicherlich auch geholfen, wobei wir nie jemanden deswegen einladen, aber das wisst ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die Downloads sind allerdings weniger als die europäischen Ligaturen. Nur in den Top-Folgen ist das so. Der Schnitt ist viel, viel niedriger. Der liegt so bei 9.000 bis 10.000 Views. Ist so ein bisschen schwer zusammenzurechnen. Und der Schnitt für die europäischen Videos, der liegt bei 11.000 bzw. bei 3.500 für die Einzelvideos und die Downloads liegen bei 11.000. Entschuldigung, ich habe hier gerade die Zahlen miteinander verwechselt. Aber was jetzt quasi jenseits von den Einzelzahlen für euch wichtig ist zu wissen. Also zum einen ist es so, dass kein Format der Liga Tour auch nur annähernd an irgendwas rankommt, was wir zur ersten Liga machen, bei den Männern. Und vor allem das Zweite ist, obwohl wir da jetzt Geld und Zeit investieren und eine Regelmäßigkeit herstellen, tut sich da leider immer noch gar nichts. Also weder das europäische Format noch das Zweitliga-Format hat irgendeine Entwicklung nach oben zu zeigen. Und wer ich nehme eigentlich auch nicht, war, dass sich da jetzt irgendwie eine neue Community drum herum bildet. Ich weiß, dass die Lieblingsformate von vielen von euch sind. Gerade das europäische Liga Tour-Format ist es von uns auch, ehrlicherweise. Es macht einfach sehr viel Spaß, mit einer etwas festeren Runde zu sprechen, die sich auch gut kennt und die einfach sehr viel Spaß hat, auch abseits des Mikrofons. Aber ehrlicherweise zeigt sich das trotz aller Bemühungen nicht in den Downloads. Und das kann vielleicht irgendwann mal auch zu Konsequenzen führen. Müssen wir mal gucken. Kann man jetzt so nicht sagen. Aber auch dafür haben wir die Hörerinnenbefragung. Bin mal gespannt, wie da die Rückmeldungen drauf sind.
Absolut, ja.
Tribünengespräch, der Podcast 85.000 Downloads, YouTube 22.000. Wir haben während der EM allein 23.000 Downloads gesammelt über die Nationalismus-Folge und die Polizeikosten-Folge. Bei YouTube haben wir immer so einen Schnitt von etwa 4.000 Views. So grob für ein Tribünengespräch. Ist ein bisschen schade, weil die Tribünengespräche ja eigentlich zeitlos sind und auch bei YouTube über die Suchfunktion häufiger gefunden werden könnten. Aber dann ist das Format wahrscheinlich doch zu sperrig. Insgesamt muss man sagen, dass es etwas enttäuschend ist, dass ausgerechnet dieses eigentlich mal so als Premium-Format gedachte Sendungstypus, jetzt wollte ich nicht nochmal Format sagen, dass das mit 16.000 Downloads dann doch gar nicht so viele Leute da draußen hören. Und ich habe den Eindruck, das ist aber auch ein bisschen ein selbstgemachtes Problem, weil es auch daran liegt, dass oft zu lange nichts passiert im Feed des Tribünengesprächs. Das wissen wir, es wäre natürlich einfacher, wenn ihr wisst, jeden Monat kommt ein Tribünengespräch, dann hört man da jeden Tag.
Eigentlich ein dauerhafter Painpoint bei uns.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Wir sprechen da, glaube ich, auch schon zum fünften Mal in irgendwelchen Q&A-Folgen drüber. Eigentlich hätten wir uns für das Tribünengespräch immer viel mehr vorgenommen, als dann am Ende machbar ist. Und aus vielen anderen Gründen, weil halt natürlich die aktuellen Sendungen sich selber auf die Agenda setzen. Die Spieltage und EMs und WM dieser Welt und die Tribünengespräche sind da geduldig. Und zu diesem Thema, das Max vorhin schon angekündigt hat, werden wir ja vielleicht noch ein paar Takte sagen. Das macht es alles gar nicht einfacher im Moment. Deine Fußballtaktik bei fast 1000 Notiz musst du mir noch erklären, Max.
Ach so, ja, das ist, also ich habe quasi gerade gesagt, 16.000 haben die EM-Tribünengespräche geholt und das Polizeikosten. Und im selben Zeitraum hat das Fußballtaktik-Gespräch 1000 Downloads geholt. Weil das ist so ein Ever-Creep.
Immer noch.
Der wird immer noch gehört. Und ich liebe es. Ich hasse es natürlich, weil ich damals so noch viel schlechterer Moderator war und Audioqualität war noch nicht so gut. Und ich glaube, weiß gerade gar nicht, ob wir da überhaupt damals schon eine Intro-Musik hatten. Müsste ich noch mal reinhören. Und hoffentlich sind hier nicht die Kapitelmarken geschrottet. Fällt mir gerade siehend heiß ein, sollte man mal nachgucken. Aber ja, es ist schön zu sehen, diese Sendung geht hier ja um Downloads.
Gibt gar kein Video von dieser Sendung.
Es gibt kein Video von dieser Sendung.
Stell dir mal vor, es würde ein Video geben zu dieser Sendung.
Ja, vor allem mit Tobi Escher, der den ganzen Bonus-Liga-Feh mit reinholt.
Und Taktik-Tafel als dritte Kamera quasi.
Ja, wobei, das ist, haben wir ja auch schon oft darüber diskutiert, wie viel einfacher auch die Spieltagsbesprechung werden würde, wenn man mal was einblenden würde oder was zeigen würde. Aber die Gefahr wäre riesengroß, dass du es als Audio dann nicht mehr checkst. Deswegen würde ich Tobi Escher die Taktik-Tafel verbieten oder verboten haben. Kommen wir zum letzten Feed, die Nationalteams. 250.000 Podcast-Downloads, 90.000 bei YouTube. Wir haben EM-Folgen zum Teil da noch mit drin, weil da ja das Finale dann erst im Juli stattfand. Die EM-Folgen hatten immer so 16.000 bis 20.000 Downloads. Also wirklich sehr erfolgreich, kann man sagen. Auch im Vergleich mit den anderen Formaten. Und grundsätzlich ist es so, dass die Länderspiele der Männer so um die 13.000 Downloads als Podcast haben. Bei YouTube immer so zwischen 6.000 und 7.000 stehen. Und die der Frauen sind bei 7.000 Downloads und bei 2.000 bis 3.000 Views bei YouTube. Man muss dazu sagen, auch hier wissen wir natürlich auch nicht, ob Download jetzt bedeutet, man hat reingehört. Also vice versa. Sowohl jemand, der vielleicht wegen der Frauenspiele abonniert, der hört sich vielleicht die Männersendung nicht an und umgedreht, gibt es bitte auch, gibt es gewiss auch den Fall. Denn zwei, drei Leute, denen war es auch wichtig, uns das mitzuteilen, dass sie diese Sendung jetzt aber nicht hören. Danke, wir haben es gehört. Wir werden trotzdem über die Länderspiele der Frauen berichten, weil es ehrlich gesagt auch gerade ein bisschen spannender ist als bei den Männern. Und weil man hier eben auch sieht, gerade bei YouTube kann man das dann doch immer ganz gut ablesen. Da scheint sich so eine kleine Community zu finden. Und ganz interessant, während die Nationalteams folgen bei den Männern, selbst Leuten, die eigentlich beruflich den Auftrag haben, so ein bisschen im Blick zu behalten, was über den DFB gesagt wird, nicht wirklich ankommen auf die Frauensendung, da gibt es aber aus allen möglichen Richtungen aus dem Fußball-Business-Rückmeldung. Das kann ich euch sagen. Also das ist sehr, sehr interessant und macht natürlich auch Spaß. Dafür machen wir die Sache nicht, aber es ist ein netter Nebeneffekt. Wir hatten auch Copa America-Sendungen. Danke nochmal an Johannes, der das damals gerockt hat. Die lagen immer so bei 9000 Downloads, also so rund die Hälfte der EM-Folgen. Wie viele dann reingehörten, wissen wir nicht, aber es war auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen, wie das.
Und der entscheidende Punkt bei all diesen Zahlen ist ja immer schön auf die Zahlen zu gucken und dann sagen wir natürlich, wie zufrieden wir damit sind oder ob wir gerne Wachstum sehen würden und so, wie wir immer wieder sagen. Und auch an dieser Stelle sollte es nochmal betont werden, am Ende zählt für uns natürlich zum einen eure Zufriedenheit, das heißt ja, eine ansteigende Download-Zahlen sind natürlich für uns auch eine Form vom Feedback, also Wachstum heißt auch, es kommt gut an. Das ist das eine. Und am anderen Ende, wenn es um das Finanzielle geht und um die Finanzierbarkeit des Rasenfunks, zählt natürlich, wie viele Supporter können wir gewinnen. Und diesen Connect kann man so direkt natürlich nicht herstellen, weil nur eine Ligatur der zweiten Liga, die jetzt enorm viele Views bekommt, erhöht natürlich nicht die Supporter-Zahlen. Insofern ist das immer so ein bisschen als Gesamtschwamm zu sehen, würde ich sagen. Wenn sich die Downloads insgesamt positiv entwickeln, bedeutet das für uns unterm Strich auch, dass sich wahrscheinlich die Supporter positiv entwickeln. Aber es ist natürlich immer ein sehr starker Gummibandeffekt. Der zieht so hinterher und ganz langsam und ist natürlich auch an sich schon schwer, statistisch zu erfassen, weil wir da im Grunde auch nur die Jahressumme zusammennehmen können und auch schlecht reinblecken können, was passiert da wirklich. Aber das ist eigentlich der einzige Grund für uns, die Download-Zahlen zu beurteilen, weil alles andere, wie Max schon sagte, ist für uns eigentlich gar nicht so relevant.
Deshalb füllt die Hörerinnenbefragung aus. Die ist für uns wirklich ein wichtiges Tool. Wir kommen zu inhaltlichen Fragen. Ich versuche jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller drüber zu gehen, damit wir möglichst viele Themenbereiche noch schaffen. Hakuna Matata hat auch gefragt, hast du einen Unterschied festgestellt, seitdem der Rasenfunk auch als Video veröffentlicht wird? Ich schaue aus Prinzip keine Podcasts bei YouTube und habe das Gefühl, dass in den letzten Wochen die nonverbale Kommunikation mehr wurde. Ich kann da tatsächlich mal eine kurze Antwort geben. Ja, ich sehe einen Unterschied und es ist alles besser geworden, dadurch, dass die Gäste sich jetzt gegenseitig sehen. Und zwar auch das Audioprodukt ist besser geworden. Denn ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen, vorher hatten wir ein Tool, da hat man nur einen Balken gesehen, wenn jemand gesprochen hat. Und ansonsten hast du gar keine Rückmeldung bekommen. Und ich habe sehr früh, als wir das mit Video gemacht haben, gemerkt, wie sehr das die Gäste entspannt, wenn sie in ihrem Monolog, den sie ja naturgemäß immer wieder haben, sehen, die anderen nicken, sie grinsen vielleicht mal bei einem Spruch, vielleicht tun sie auch schon mal so Luft und man merkt, ok, da habe ich jetzt was gesagt, da möchte jemand gleich noch einhaken. Es macht alles besser, sowohl das Audioformat als auch das Videoformat ist auch natürlich logischerweise jetzt mit einer Videospur auch gut. Also das hat sich wirklich sehr bezahlt gemacht und es macht mehr Spaß, damit aufzunehmen. Weitere Frage nach den Formaten. Wie zufrieden seid ihr selbst aktuell mit dem Produkt Rasenfunk, gerade nachdem sich inzwischen Änderungen wie die Feeds, Position des Werbeblocks, Abgabe der zweiten Liga, YouTube, Unterteilung von Spieltag und Schwerpunkt und so weiter und so fort etabliert haben. Dazu fragt auch noch Nono, ob ich eigentlich alle Rasenfunkfolgen höre, die ich nicht selbst moderiere. Aber auf jeden Fall Nono, aber ganz, ganz sicher. Ich versuche auch möglichst oft Feedback dazu zu geben und den Gästen auch nochmal zu danken. Und gibt es Gedanken dazu, wie man in Zukunft den Rasenfunk noch erweitern kann. Vielleicht ein Champions League Format. Flona Deniu hat diesen Evergreen der Rasenfunk-Fragen gestellt. Ich versuche jetzt auch hier nicht so sehr herum zu mehr anderen, weil da könnten wir jetzt natürlich sehr, sehr viel zu sagen. Also grundsätzlich glauben wir oder glaube ich, ich möchte jetzt nicht für dich sprechen, Frank, das gerne gleich ergänzen. Ich glaube, dass der Rasenfunk inhaltlich besser dasteht denn je. Die Aufteilung in Spieltag und Vereinsschwerpunkt war lange überfällig. Sag ich gleich noch was mit dazu, was das aber auch bewirkt. Die Art und Weise, wie wir die Sendung beginnen, hat zwar mein Audiodesign von Intro und Outro aufgebrochen, weil das Radio wird angeschaltet und das Radio wird abgeschaltet, weil wir sind ja der Rasenfunk. Eigentlich darfst du da nicht einen Codeopener davor machen, bevor das Radio angeschaltet wird. Ich glaube aber, dass es hilft. Manchmal überrascht das wahrscheinlich, wenn man quasi einfach die Podcast-Que durchhört und dann eben ohne Intro losgeredet wird. Ich glaube aber, dass es auch einfacher wird, eine Orientierung zu finden. Und wir sind ein bisschen entspannter bei der Begrüßung damit geworden, weil dann könnte man rein theoretisch auch mal einfach ein bisschen labern, bevor die Sendung losgeht. Also ich glaube inhaltlich, wir decken auch viel mehr ab als in der Vergangenheit und stehen mit Ausnahme des Tribünengesprächs-Feets wirklich sehr, sehr gut inhaltlich da. Aber, und jetzt kommt das aber, der Output ist brutal. Also ihr merkt es als HörerInnen denke ich ja auch, dass wir in der Regel stehen wir gerade bei vier Sendungen pro Woche. Und was ich, also was wir eigentlich wussten und deswegen haben wir diese Aufteilung in Schwerpunkt versus Spieltagssendung so lange nicht gemacht. Das war nicht nur ein finanzielles Thema, weil mehr Gäste, sondern vor allem eben eine Sendung mehr pro Woche. Und man unterschätzt es immer wieder, auch ich unterschätze es immer wieder, wie KO man nach einer Sendung sein kann. Also das ist im Grunde ist das nur anderthalb Stunden Gespräch und dann irgendwie noch eine Stunde Nachbearbeitung. Dann schaust du noch, dass alles passt und dann du kannst da rein theoretisch mit vier bis fünf Stunden Aufwand rauskommen. Das ist ja gar nicht so viel, da hat man ja noch einen halben Arbeitstag. Aber de facto ist es nicht so. Und wir stoßen da trotz aller Bemühungen mit Gäste, ModeratorInnen und so weiter und so fort. Wir stoßen da an Grenzen und müssen da auch gucken, wie es weitergeht, weil das ist ein Pensum. Das ist wahrscheinlich leider zu viel.
Oder zumindest so nicht weitermachbar. Und wenn Max wir sagt, dann geht es in erster Linie natürlich um Max, der da viel mehr und viel praktischer involviert ist als jeder andere. Aber auch das ist wieder ein Punkt, wo diese Umfrage ganz, ganz arg wichtig für uns ist, weil wir dafür ein bisschen mehr sehen müssen, wie schaut ihr auf die einzelnen Sendungen? Wie hört ihr sie? Wie wichtig sind sie euch? Wie beurteilt ihr sie? Das wird ein Punkt sein, an den wir irgendwie ran müssen. Das wird Teil unserer Besprechung in sechs Wochen sein. Aber das wird vor allem Gegenstand der nächsten Monate wahrscheinlich sein, um herauszufinden, wie organisieren wir gewisse Dinge? Wollen wir die eine oder andere Sendung anders strukturieren? Weil was natürlich jetzt nicht so deutlich rauskam, bei dem was Max eben gesagt hat, aber was ihr eigentlich, vor allem ihr als Hörer dieses Q&A, die ja wahrscheinlich regelmäßige Rasenfunk-Hörer seid, was ihr wisst, der wahre Aufwand steckt in der Vorbereitung. Der meisten Sendungen. Sprich allein zweieinhalb Tage wahrscheinlich gehen drauf, um die ganzen Sendungen, die ganzen Spiele des Spieltags zu sehen. Und was eben notwendig ist für eine tiefe Analyse, wie ihr es vom Rasenfunk gewohnt seid. Also die Frage wird für uns sein, an welcher Stelle können wir das managen mit zusätzlichen Menschen oder mit Veränderung der Formate oder vielleicht auch mit der Streichung des ein oder anderen Formats, keine Ahnung. Würde zwar davon jetzt nicht ausgehen, aber am Ende müssen wir halt gucken, dass vor allem die wichtigen Produkte nicht leiden, dadurch dass das Pensum insgesamt zu hoch ist. Ich glaube, das ist schon ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Und da werden wir in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten irgendwie damit umgehen. Dass man meistens den Mut fassen muss, was größer zu ändern. Und wir haben das ja gemacht. Wir haben die Nameschlusskonferenz verworfen, wo viele erstmal einen Schreck bekommen haben. Wir haben das Format verändert. Viele haben einen Schreck bekommen. Und am Ende ist aber unser Fazit. Und ich kann eigentlich nur Armen sagen, zu dem, was du vorhin gesagt hast. Ich sehe es genauso. Wir sind inhaltlich besser aufgestellt. Die inhaltlichen Detailänderungen, wie der Coldopener, YouTube sowieso, hat alles dem Produkt Rasenfunk wahnsinnig gut getan. Und am Ende können wir, glaube ich, es auch so sehen. Wir waren nicht ganz so skeptisch. Wir waren eigentlich sehr positiv. Aber es ist eben schön zu lesen, dass diejenigen oder jemand in dem Fall, der am Anfang skeptisch war, das jetzt alles ganz toll finden und sich gar nicht mehr anders vorstellen kann. Das ist eigentlich das schönste Kompliment für diesen Weg.
Und dazu muss man sagen, also bei dem ging es jetzt eben darum, um die Schwerpunkt-Aufteilung, also raus aus der Spieltagssendung. Übrigens hat es die Schwerpunkte viel besser gemacht. Sie sind länger geworden. In der Regel haben sie noch mal eine ganz andere Gesprächsatmosphäre. Und dazu muss man aber auch sagen, uns ist auch sehr bewusst, also das soll jetzt hier nicht wie Beklagen über die Situation ankommen, weil das ist ja alles von uns selber produziert. Wir haben uns selber quasi dazu entschieden, auch dieses Pensum zu machen. Wir wussten auch, was da auf uns zukommt. Aber wir müssen jetzt feststellen, dass es dann doch in der Art und Weise vielleicht nicht für immer funktioniert. Also nicht mit einem langfristigen Gedanken, weil sonst irgendwann die Qualität leidet. Und das ist eben der Punkt, der nicht passieren darf. Wir wollen immer auf einem gewissen Standard bleiben, weil wir glauben, dass das der Kern des Rasenfunks ist. Und daher kommen diese Überlegungen und daher kommt auch so mancher Gedanke. Und deswegen wird es auch erstmal kein Champions League-Format geben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, um die Frage zu beantworten, ich glaube, das können wir ausschließen erstmal.
Ja, das wird tatsächlich nicht passieren. Aber deswegen glauben wir, dass es inhaltlich ganz gut ist aktuell. Aber auch da Hörerinnenbefragung, wir sind total gespannt, was ihr eigentlich denkt. Denn wir bekommen ja immer nur so ein loses Feedback und vor allem von den Vielhörern. Und mich würden die Nebenbeihörer auch ehrlicherweise mal sehr interessieren.
Und ich will noch mal ganz kurz so eine Schleife zurückmachen. Wir haben an irgendeinem Punkt heute darüber gesprochen, warum wir eigentlich immer wachsen wollen. Das ist hier relativ gut sichtbar. Wachsen heißt ja für uns auch ein Stück weit, was können wir machen, um neue Hörer zu erreichen? Und zum Teil ist die jetzige Formataufstellung ja auch eine, also es ist natürlich eine inhaltliche Überzeugung von uns, aber zum Teil ja auch eine Idee und diese Aufsplittungen in mehrere Feeds, eine Idee, Hörer besser gezielter anzusprechen, um sie besser zu erreichen und im Ergebnis natürlich mehr zu erreichen. Mehr Unterstützer zu gewinnen, hätte zur Folge, dass wir uns leichter tun würden, nicht unbedingt inhaltlich, weil das ist natürlich mit dem Anspruch, den wir haben, inhaltlich gar nicht so einfach, aber dass wir uns leichter tun würden, uns personell zu verstärken, um dann im Ergebnis wieder flexibler zu sein, was den Output angeht. Also, es hängt alles ein bisschen zusammen. Wir haben nicht Wachstum im Sinne, auch wenn Max es vorhin scherzhaft auf die Weltherrschaft gelingt hat, Wachstum des Wachstums will und weil wir gerne Millionäre werden, sondern einfach Wachstum, weil dann der Rasenfunk auf besseren, gesünderen Beinen stehen würde, weil es uns leichter fallen würde, andere Leute mit an Bord zu holen, die uns helfen, dieses Ziel, das wir mit dem Rasenfunk haben, umzusetzen. Insofern ist, glaube ich, die Frage damit ganz gut beantwortet. Würden wir ab sofort 20 Prozent mehr Einnahmen haben, würden wir uns wesentlich leichter tun, jemanden zusätzlich mit an Bord zu holen. Stattdessen kämpfen wir jetzt mit potenziellen weniger Einnahmen durch Kontoumstellungen. Aber das ist halt einfach der tägliche Business-Struggle dann am Ende.
Ja, und dazu muss man sagen, wir haben ja eine eingepreiste Inflation, nur die wirkt sich bei uns anders aus. Also wir müssen auch deshalb wachsen, weil wir ja auch immer wieder Supporterinnen verlieren. Also der normale Lebenszyklus eines Supporters oder einer Supporterin, der endet irgendwann, weil sich Lebensumstände verändern, finanzielle Situationen verändert, weil man auch vielleicht einfach keine Lust mehr hat, vielleicht auch inhaltlich nicht zufrieden ist. Wir wissen das ehrlicherweise nicht. Die melden sich sehr, sehr selten bei uns. Wenn sie sich melden, dann hat es inhaltlich eigentlich nie was zu tun. Dann wollen sie uns sagen, ich würde euch so gern unterstützen, aber ich kann nicht mehr oder ich interessiere mich einfach nicht mehr für den Fußball. Und das müssen wir auch auffangen. Also allein dafür bräuchten wir ein geringes Wachstum, immer um neue Leute finden zu können, die da nachwachsen. Damit sind wir schon wieder beim Geldthema gelandet. Wir haben vorhin schon einige Fragen von euch, die in Richtung Geld gingen, beantworten, was vor allem die Gästehonorare angeht. Und ich glaube, ihr könnt euch dadurch jetzt auch schon ganz gut zusammenreimen, dass natürlich unterschiedliche Formate unterschiedlich hohe Ausgaben haben. Wir versuchen das aber nicht so miteinander zu verrechnen. Aber es gibt noch einen ganz, ganz großen Punkt beim Geldthema, der uns auch sehr wichtig ist und der ehrlicherweise mir persönlich auch sehr schwer im Magen liegt. Deswegen habe ich da auch in dem Rasenfunk-Newsletter an alle Supporterinnen auch schon mal was zu geschrieben, nämlich die Frage nach der Transparenz. Warum findet man bei uns auf der Seite, also es ging ja quasi bis hin zu, man könnte es ja bis auf jeden Cent hin aufschlüsseln oder zumindest eine Tortengrafik, die sagt, so und so viel Prozent eures Geldes gehen an XY und so weiter. Vor allem, nachdem wir das ja in der letzten Sendung dieser Art schon mal aufgedröset haben. Also die Zahlen dazu, die Prozentzahlen, die prozentuale Verteilung, die gibt es und die sollte eigentlich dann auch auf der Webseite landen. Kleine Hintergrundgeschichte dazu. Es gab dann mal wieder eine Ausgabe, von der wir nicht wussten, dass wir die noch tätigen müssen als GmbH. Die muss noch eingerechnet werden. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass bei den Prozentzahlen, die wir genannt haben, das hat im Großen zum Glück nichts verändert. Aber der Teil unbeachtet geblieben ist, dass wir natürlich auch ein bisschen was zurückgelegt haben, weil wir ja eben nicht irgendwie rein raus auf einer Null arbeiten wollen, so wie alle Bundesligisten, sondern uns ja eben darauf einrichten wollen, dass eben auch mal was zurückgeht. Oder zum Beispiel eine Kamera für YouTube gekauft werden muss, die euch vielleicht schon aufgefallen ist, liebe YouTube-Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer. Also das ist einer der Gründe, warum wir das nicht veröffentlicht haben. Und dann ist grundsätzlich Transparenz bei diesen Zahlen für mich zumindest ein wirklich schwieriges Thema. Und ich muss dazu ganz kurz ausholen. Es stellt sich ja wirklich die Frage, warum veröffentlichen wir nicht jede Zahl? Und ich persönlich möchte das deshalb nicht, wegen einem Prozent von euch. Oder wahrscheinlich ist es weniger. 0,15 Prozent von euch. Es gibt einen ganz, ganz, ganz verschwindend geringen Teil von Menschen da draußen, die uns und in dem Fall auch mir persönlich nichts Gutes wollen und die darauf warten, irgendetwas zum Vorwurf machen zu können. Aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen und die das vielleicht auch gar nicht immer so merken, was sie tun. Also als Beispiel will ich einmal illustrieren. Ich habe ja sehr prominent im Rasenfunk nach einer neuen Bleibe für die Zwillinge und mich gesucht. Warum habe ich das gemacht? Weil wir keine Chance hatten, auf dem völlig kranken Münchner Wohnungsmarkt. Es ist kein leichter Schritt, mit so was in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen. Und dann melden sich Leute und ich verstehe das, dass sie sich melden und sagen, ey, das gibt es ja nicht. Du willst mehr für eine Wohnung ausgeben, als ich netto im Monat verdiene. Und das schürt sehr viel Frust und Wut. Und das Ding ist, ich bin genauso wütend. Also was ich dann zurückgeschrieben habe, ist ja, und ich finde das für uns beide scheiße. Es ist falsch, dass ich so viel Geld allein für eine Wohnung zahlen soll im München. Und ich finde es genauso scheiße, dass du so wenig verdienst. Und es gibt dann aber auch Leute, die dann gewisse Grenzen überschreiten, die meiner Meinung nach nicht überschritten gehören. Also dann wird einem auch geraten, zieh du einfach an das Bundesland. Warum musst du überhaupt deine Kinder 50-50 betreuen? Also ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, wer sich da in welcher Art und Weise dann doch auch meldet. Und das halte ich aus. Und das führt aber dazu, dass ich, obwohl ich weiß, dass 99,9 Prozent von euch da draußen, wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel unsere Geschäftsführergehälter sehen würden, dass die da gar nichts zuzusagen hätten und das einordnen können, den Kontext dazu kennen. Vielleicht auch den Unterschied kennen zwischen, zahlt man eine Wohnung und Lebenshaltungskosten in München oder woanders und uns das nicht missgönnen. Obwohl ich das weiß, möchte ich diese Zahlen dann doch nicht im Internet haben. Weil ich glaube, dass ich nicht mit den Nadelstichen, die durch einzelne E-Mails dann gerne anonym reinkommen, auf Dauer umgehen könnte, weil wir ja selber darunter leiden, wie unsere Welt ökonomisch so aufgebaut ist. Also Frank und ich, ich spreche jetzt wieder für dich, aber wir sind ja beide so, dass wir das nicht gut finden, wie ungleich Einkommen verteilt sind, wie schlecht bezahlt viele Berufe sind, die wirklich wichtig sind, wie überbezahlt dann wir vielleicht auch sind. Also im Vergleich dazu sind wir definitiv überbezahlt, weil unsere Arbeit ist nicht so wichtig. Und deswegen wird es, glaube ich, die volle Transparenz nie geben können, weil ich glaube, ich halte das nicht aus. Und das hat mir wirklich diese Wohnungsnummer auch nochmal gezeigt. Da gab es eklige Reaktionen, ganz, ganz wenige, aber es gab sie.
Ja, und du sprichst da völlig zurecht für mich, weil ich es im Grunde ganz genauso sehe. Wir haben uns ja auch vor dieser Wohnungssache schon darüber unterhalten und waren uns im Grunde einig. Dass wir Transparenz schaffen wollen, insofern, dass wir euch zeigen, wofür geben wir euer Geld aus, was aber eben nicht heißen kann, dass wir damit auf die einzelne Buchung zurückgehen oder euch, keine Ahnung, andere Summen nennen, die eben Raum bieten für solche Menschen und für solche Aktionen. Drum gehen wir eben ein bisschen bewusst damit um, wie wir es veröffentlichen, in welcher Form und in welchem Detailgrad. Wir hoffen und euer Feedback zeigt es im Grunde, dass das genug ist, dass ihr uns vertrauen könnt, dass wir damit nicht, ich glaube, ich habe sie irgendwo im Notizdokument gerade gelesen, nicht damit an die Börse gehen, zu spekulieren, wobei das tatsächlich noch einer der harmloseren Dinge ist, die ich mir jetzt vorstellen könnte, die man mit, wie man Geld voruntreuen kann oder, na ja, eben Schindluder damit treiben. Nein, wir investieren nicht in Krypto, auch nicht in Tesla-Aktien. Wir sind da relativ konservativ. Wir versuchen natürlich, Rücklagen zu bilden, aber um ehrlich zu sein und ohne da jetzt ins Detail zu gehen, so viel höher sind die Einnahmen nicht als die Ausgaben, dass diese Rücklagen riesig sein können. Wir operieren hier auch, wenn es eine GmbH ist, im Grunde mit relativ kleinen Summen. In erster Linie, ja, in erster Linie. Aber wir haben die, Max sagt es gerade, wir haben die die Verteilung beim letzten Mal veröffentlicht, da gegenüber hat sich seither nicht so massiv viel geändert. Wir planen es auf jeden Fall, auf der Website zu tun in Form von einem Kuchendiagramm, damit ihr seht, wo geht anteilig das Geld hin. Und ich glaube, es sind ja im Wesentlichen die Gästehonorare, die Gehälter und ein paar technische Ausgaben. Und dann war es das im Grunde. Also ist es alles nicht so fürchterlich komplex.
Na gut, und Steuern und Abgaben, Frank. Das ist der eine Punkt, der mit dazu gab. Ich könnte ja sagen, KSK-Abgabe für Gäste, die bei uns drin sind, hatten wir nicht auf dem Schirm, wussten wir nicht. Und müssen wir halt jetzt rückwirkend abführen.
Künstler-Sozialkanzler, für diejenigen, die nicht sofort wissen, worum es geht.
Gäste bei uns, die einen Honorar bekommen haben, deren Hauptschwerpunkt beruflich eine künstlerische Tätigkeit ist oder eine publizistische Tätigkeit, da müssen wir einfach noch mal zusätzlich, inzwischen sind es 5 Prozent, vorher waren es 4,5 Prozent des Netto-Betrags, an die KSK überweisen.
So viel übrigens auch zu Folgen der Erhöhung der Gästehonorare.
Ja, genau, das mussten wir auch damit reinrechnen. Also es war gar nicht so trivial. Zum Glück hast du da diese tolle Taschenrechner-App, mit der du das alles gemacht hast. Und mit Taschenrechner-App war es schon eine Beleidigung der App. Aber das zum Beispiel ist mit draufgekommen, nachdem wir die Zahlen genannt hatten, weil wir uns dessen einfach nicht bewusst waren. Das war ein Fehler unsererseits. Und dann haben sich aber die Zahlen wieder verändert und wir wussten aber auch gleich noch gar nicht, wie viel das sein würde. Also ich musste dann für jedes Gästehonorar seit 2018 eine Zuweisung durchführen. Ist das jetzt jemand, der sonst einen Hauptjob hat, der eine andere Tätigkeit ist oder der eben darunter fällt und musste das für jedes einzelne Honorar machen? Das haben wir der KSK gemeldet und dann dauert sowas ja so ewig. Also wir haben jetzt für das für 2023, glaube ich, haben wir jetzt den Betrag, den für 2024 haben wir gemeldet und quasi das passt. Und ab jetzt zahlen wir voraus. Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr so ein ewiges Hin und Her. Aber die alten Sachen, da habe ich, glaube ich, immer noch keine Rückmeldung bekommen. Ich bin mir sogar sicher, dass ich nur keine bekommen habe. Also das kam auch mit rein. Und das sind dann halt auch ein paar Tausend Euro. Und dann verändern sich die Prozente zahlen dann doch wieder. Aber es liegt uns auch schwer im Magen. Wir wollen transparenter sein. Die volle Transparenz wird es aus den genannten Gründen allerdings nicht geben können. Und einen Punkt kann ich dann vielleicht aus den Hinterkulissen und privaten Fragen dann da noch mit dazu ziehen. Ich denke, ihr habt das gemerkt. Ich hoffe, ihr habt es dem Produkt Rasenfunk nicht angemerkt. Aber ich spreche jetzt mal für mich und du kannst sagen, was du willst für dich, Frank. Aber das zweite Halbjahr im letzten Jahr waren die krassesten Monate, die ich vielleicht seit mindestens zehn Jahren erlebt habe. Das war von der Belastung her in sämtlichen Lebensbereichen ultra hart. Wirklich ultra. Und in dieser Situation war ich gottfroh, irgendwie den Betrieb im Rasenfunk aufrechterhalten zu können. Und dass man das nicht allzu doll merkt, könnte man bei YouTube gucken, an welchen Orten ich alles Sendung gemacht habe. Das gibt schon mal so einen kleinen Hinweis darauf, wie das alles war. Und da war dann an solche Themen leider gar nicht mehr zu denken. Also das muss ich auch tatsächlich sagen. Das ist dann natürlich auch schlecht und nicht gut, dass wir dann ausgerechnet mit der Transparenz auf der Webseite und wie wir das jetzt eigentlich darstellen wollen, nicht weiterkommen. Aber da lagen ganz, ganz viele andere Dinge auch noch brach. So war es im letzten Jahr bei mir und es ist auch noch nicht komplett wieder entspannt. Das wäre jetzt auch eine Lüge, das zu behaupten.
Wir müssen da auch, glaube ich, insgesamt einfach sagen, eure Nachfragen dazu sind alle völlig berechtigt. Keiner ist damit böse oder irgendwas in irgendeiner Form. Aber aus unserer Sicht müssen wir einfach auch sagen, diese Dinge können wir auch neben dem Normalbetrieb, was ja im Rasenfunk immer noch der Podcast ist und die Produktion immer nur dann machen, wenn dafür Zeit ist. Und das ist ganz wichtig und gerade jetzt, wie Max geschildert hat, wenn so eine Stressphase im Leben, im Job, was auch immer ist, solche Dinge dauern dann halt einfach ein bisschen und ihr müsst da einfach uns vertrauen, dass wir trotzdem keinen Unsinn machen und dass diese Dinge trotzdem irgendwann kommen, auch wenn sie ein bisschen länger dauern, weil es eben, ja, es soll gar nicht negativ oder abwertend klingen, aber es sind zweitrangige Dinge. Vorrangig ist da eben der Betrieb des Podcasts und die Produktion der Inhalte.
Gebt uns auch dazu gerne Feedback. Reicht euch das? Oder ist das vielleicht auch ein Grund, warum ihr nicht supportet oder nicht mehr supportet? Das wäre natürlich auch sehr wichtig zu wissen. Aber gut, die Hörerinnenbefragung. Wie oft habe ich es jetzt heute? Das wäre ein gutes Trinkspiel gewesen für diese Sendung. Na ja, vielleicht treffe ich es noch in die Show Notes.
Vielleicht gut. Es ist Vormittag.
Für uns ist Vormittag. Wann das hier veröffentlicht wird, weiß ich gerade tatsächlich nicht.
So viel zum Blick hinter die Kulissen. Es ist Vormittag.
Ja, aber nur auf ganz knapp Vormittag muss man sagen.
Es ist auch die Überschrift des nächsten Absatzes im Notizdokument.
Okay, du bist bei einem anderen Absatz als ich.
Ich bin schon zu weit gerutscht.
Ja, aber wirklich. Also, manche Fragen werden wir jetzt nicht beantworten. Es gab viele private Fragen. Es gab auch so Fragen zu sportlichen Themen, wie ich zum Mann gegen Mann-Pressing und so weiter stehe. Das passt jetzt leider nicht mehr hier rein. Zeitlich gesehen, weil wir auflaufen.
Solche Themen passen übrigens immer besser ins Forum. Um nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, bitte auch keine Mails schreiben. Das ist wirklich lieb. Aber solche, wenn da manchmal so ein Brett und E-Mail kommen, dann denkt man sich wahnsinnig geil, wie jemand wirklich Zeit investiert hat, um da tiefgründig einzusteigen. Aber in den meisten Fällen ist es wirklich schwer, da inhaltlich darauf einzugehen. Wenn ihr das ins Forum schreibt, erlebt ihr eine viel vitalere Diskussion dazu. Und Max und ich haben trotzdem die Gelegenheit, damit einzusteigen, wenn es passt.
Und gerade die lange und ausführlich formulierten Mails, die bleiben leider bei mir manchmal liegen, weil ich möchte dann mit einem ähnlichen Aufwand antworten und kriege den dann nicht gestemmt. Also ich möchte beschämte Grüße an den Hörer und Supporter schicken, der mir einen Zeitartikel zur ökonomischen Situation unter anderem in Leipzig geschickt hat im Sommer. Dazu eine sehr lange E-Mail. Ich trage diese E-Mail immer noch im Kopf mit mir herum, weil ich auf sie antworten will und kriege es aber einfach nicht hin. Und inzwischen kann man sich wirklich einfach nur dafür schämen. Aber so ist es eben leider. Ihr habt viele Fragen zu hinter den Kulissen und sportlichen Einschätzungen, und so weiter, gefragt. Ich würde jetzt aber noch mal die rauspicken, die tatsächlich auch für den Ablauf des Rasenfunks relevant sind. Und da gibt es vor allem drei Personen, nach denen ihr quasi indirekt gefragt habt. Nämlich, was hat sich verändert dadurch, dass wir mit Moritz jetzt jemanden haben, der uns beim Guested-Management hilft? Und was hat sich dadurch verändert, dass wir mit Marc und Eva ein Moderatorinnen-Duo haben, das die zweite Liga übernommen hat? Ich beginne mal mit Moritz. Es ist ein Segen. Er ist ein Segen. Es ist das, was wir erhofft haben. Es ist ein bisschen ernüchternd zu sehen, obwohl mir so viel jetzt abgenommen wird durch Moritz. Das Guested-Management, es war die Hölle, ich sage es einfach wie es ist. Das hat an manchen Tagen 70 Prozent des Tages angenommen. Man mag es gar nicht glauben. Obwohl so viel besser geworden ist, bin ich immer noch voll ausgelastet. Ich hätte es mir ein bisschen anders gewünscht, aber das heißt nicht, dass er nicht eine riesengroße Hilfe ist. Die ist er und es ist eine ganz große Entlastung. Vor allem auch viele administrative Dinge nicht mehr im Kopf behalten zu müssen. Es ist auch wie Mental Load, der mir abgenommen wird. Also ich weiß jetzt eben zum Beispiel bei Neulingen im Podcast, die bekommen den mitwirkenden Vertrag zugeschickt und da wird auch nachgehackt, dass sie ihn bitte unterschreiben und zurückschicken. Und ja, hast du dein Kreuz gemacht bei Umsatzsteuer? Ja oder nein? Ach, du brauchst noch Beratung dazu. Okay, das hier wären Möglichkeiten. Und hast du uns schon ein Foto fürs Thumbnail geschickt und so weiter und so fort? Das, Moritz, das macht, ist eine riesengroße Entlastung. Und es hilft total und hat sich, also hat genau den Effekt gebracht, den wir uns erhofft haben und noch viel mehr, weil Moritz ja selbst jetzt zu so einer Figur im Rasenfunkkosmos geworden ist, allein durch das Glückwunschvideo zu den zehn Jahresgeburtstag. Also es ist eine große Erleichterung und es ist auch toll, dass ihr das mit eurer Unterstützung möglich gemacht habt. Denn auch da war das ja erst mal ein finanzielles, ja doch ein kleines Risiko war es schon, das jetzt einfach zu machen, weil wir jetzt nicht irgendwie Moritz mit reinholen wollten und dann nach zwei Monaten wieder sagen wollten, okay, gut, das klappt jetzt doch nicht, sorry, du bist raus. Dafür war der Onboarding-Prozess schon allein zu lang. Aber ja, es ist eine große Entlastung und es ist super und hebt den Rasenfunk auf eine nächste Stufe. Und dann haben wir noch Mark und Eva als Moderatorinnen der Zweitligasendungen. Also ja, ich höre jede Sendung und ich bin auch sehr begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert. Und inzwischen ist auch der Schmerz nicht mehr immer da, dass ich die Sendung nicht moderieren darf, denn das ist natürlich das Dove bei so einem Typen, der immer alles selber machen will, dass er dann auch wirklich Schmerzen empfindet, wenn er jetzt nicht über den HSV und Schalke sprechen will, obwohl diejenigen, die es tun, besser vorbereitet sind, als er es geschafft hätte. Also ich finde das ganz toll, wie Eva und Mark das machen. Ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass es euch so geht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wenn dem so ist, dann lasst ihn mal ein bisschen Liebe da in den Kommentaren auf allen möglichen Plattformen. Ihr wisst ja, wie ihr sie findet und im Forum schauen sie ja auch definitiv rein. Also das funktioniert sehr gut. Es ist inhaltlich. So, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Sie stehen vor denselben technischen Hürden, die wir manchmal auch haben. Du hast manchmal einfach eine Sendung, da funktioniert das Internet beim Gast nicht. Das tröstet auch ein bisschen, ehrlich gesagt. Und vor allem, dass ich dann auch sagen kann, es ist völlig normal. Denkt euch nichts. Manchmal klappt es einfach nicht. Aber das funktioniert gut. Und weil die Frage von Schorsch dann noch kam, inwiefern sie redaktionell eingebunden sind, also eben für die zweite Liga entscheiden Mark und Eva, wie sie es machen wollen. Und ich gebe da manchmal meinen Senf zu ab. Gefragt, sehr selten auch ungefragt. Ich hoffe aber immer so, dass es für beide passt. Ansonsten meldet ihr euch mal bei mir über die entsprechenden Kanäle. Das planen alles komplett Eva und Mark gemeinsam mit Moritz. Und ihr merkt ja, wie gut das Ergebnis ist. Also das ist alles ganz wunderbar. Aber das ist derzeit auch so ihr Betätigungsfeld. Also die Schwerpunktplanung jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob das eben damit gemeint war. Die von den Männervereinen, die mache noch ich, weil das ja auch so ein bisschen korrespondiert mit mit den Spieltagssendungen und so weiter und so fort. Also wir sind sehr, sehr happy.
Absolut, ja, kann ich nur bestätigen.
Ich glaube, Frank, damit haben wir das Gro der Fragen tatsächlich geschafft.
Sieht so aus, ja, ich kann zumindest auch beim Durchscrollen nichts mehr finden, was wir jetzt nicht zumindest so entfernt abgedeckt haben, bis auf die eher privaten Dinge.
Da gibt es ehrlicherweise auch bei den privaten Dingen gibt es auch Fragen, die sich immer wieder wiederholen. Also wenn ihr jetzt das hier die erste Q&A-Folge ist, die ihr hört, dann hört doch mal in die vom letzten Jahr rein und die vom vorletzten Jahr. Da gibt es ja Kapitelmarken und so weiter und so fort. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass einige Fragen, die jetzt unbeantwortet geblieben sind, oder ich weiß es sogar, die haben wir schon relativ oft beantwortet und da hat sich dann auch nichts wirklich dran verändert. Und die Details zum neuen Rasenfunk-Headquarter, stimmt, das war noch eine Frage, die Last Minute reinkam. Ja, Internet-Download und Upload ist noch ein Thema, aber wir sind dran. Sowohl ich persönlich als auch die GmbH. Mal gucken, was sich da verändert. Aber inzwischen haben wir einen Modus, der zumindest ein halbwegs wie Wendy ist. Also es geht halbwegs aktuell und wird hoffentlich noch besser werden. Wir sind halt in Deutschland.
Und insgesamt sei gesagt, ihr könnt eure Fragen auch immer und jederzeit im Forum stellen. Also es gibt keinen Grund, da immer auf eine Q&A-Sendung zu warten. Vor allem, wenn es um so Dinge geht wie Max NFL vorlieben oder sowas. Das sind dann oft Sachen, die hier sowieso nicht so ganz gut reinpassen.
Hallo. Ich würde sagen, oder ihr hört halt einfach mal die Super Bowl Folgen, die es in dem Jahr gibt.
Oder die Super Bowl Folgen.
Also ich mache ja keinen Hilf auf.
Ich wollte sagen als Alternative. Ja, genau. Ja, also nutzt gerne und mehr das Forum. Das ist unsere liebste Plattform für Nachrichten an uns direkt oder Fragen über den Rasenfunk, Diskussionen über den Fußball oder auch über das Laravel Backend rasenfunk.de gerne, gerne dort. Da finden sich in der Regel immer andere verrückte Hörer, die in irgendeiner Form da auch mit zu tun haben. Und da habt ihr eine schöne Community und und wir freuen uns drüber.
Und fürs tägliche den C in die Community, in den Community Tümpel reinhalten, sei der Discord empfohlen. Wenn ihr einfach mal so ein bisschen wissen wollt, wie die Leute so ticken, die den Rasenfunk hören oder manche Leute ticken, dann sei euch unser inoffizieller Discord-Server auch nochmal ans Herz gelegt. Da kriegt man, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Den muss der Max jetzt aber auch in die Show Notes packen.
Ja, ja, ich habe mir hier schon Notiz gemacht. Das frage ich mich immer, ob das den YouTube-Hörern eigentlich auch fällt, was ich hier die ganze Zeit neben den Sendungen noch mache, mit meinen Kapitelmarken und mit dem Stummschalten. Und manchmal editiere ich schon live in der Sendung, wenn ich weiß, es wird mit der Produktion ein bisschen eng, oder hier mit meinen Notizen. Naja, bisher hat sich noch nie jemand dazu geäußert. Wir sollten aber noch ein paar SupporterInnen danken, oder soll ich das noch machen, Frank? Was meinst du?
Ja, mach mal, auf jeden Fall.
Dann danken wir in dieser Sendung Benéo, Superunioner, Bell vom Brentano Bart, wo ich irgendwie das Gefühl habe, wir kennen diese Bell. Herzliche Grüße, Katrin, Tim aus der Schweiz und dem ersten FC 03. Ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Und wenn ihr das noch nicht wisst, wie man uns unterstützt, dann solltet ihr jetzt wirklich auf rasenfunk.de gehen, denn es geht in jeder möglichen Form. Und letztlich haben auch alle diejenigen, die jetzt Fragen gestellt haben, diese Folge hier unterstützt. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Danke für euer Vertrauen und für eure Geduld mit euch. Auch diese Sendung ist ja jetzt leider später rausgekommen, als wir es geplant hatten. Wir sind sehr gespannt auf euer Feedback. Wir sind sehr gespannt auf eure Antworten in der Hörerinnenbefragung. Wir wünschen euch, dass ihr gesund bleibt und dass ihr uns gewogen bleibt. Bis bald, bald, ciao!
Danke, servus!
Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir grüßen alle, die uns liebhaben.